[Music]
hey friends so i just uh
went to play my guitar and i discovered
a broken string
and i thought this would be a nice
moment to offer you a
little short guitar tip so i am using
gut strings
and so this is the first time i've
broken a string actually
quite some time i have to say that when
you use synthetic strings one of the
perks
is that they're very durable and they
don't really break however they do
sometimes
um gut strings definitely break more you
can see where
it broke here right at the nut and
actually i kind of knew it was going to
happen
in advance because the string was sort
of fraying
like that and i could sort of sort of
see it coming looks like it was getting
stuck in the the groove of the nut
and then it was basically slowly yeah
fraying and i knew it was going to snap
and it finally happened um and so
there's a couple things
i wanted to recommend that you could do
if you have this happen to you um the
first thing
is to grab some sandpaper
um i have what it's like 150 grit
350 and then i have like a jeweler's
sandpaper it's like a thousand
grit the first thing to do i think to
make sure this doesn't happen again
is to sand inside the groove of my b
string the second string
because maybe there's a sharp edge in
there uh
that's the first solution and maybe
another idea is that the
the string um is actually thicker than
the groove
so that the string was riding on top of
the little slit rather than being
inside of the pocket of the thing so if
it's writing on top
it's just kind of every time i tune it
gets sawed
by the nut slot so maybe we need to
widen that nut slot
or maybe we just need a little bit of
sandpaper
and maybe we can fix the problem so i'm
going to try this like three 350 grits
uh and i'm gonna be very delicate
because i don't really want to take up
too much
um you know size
from the shape here yeah i can already
see there's a lot of dust
coming i don't know if you can see that
it's really it works fast
so you don't have to do a whole lot
that's pretty good already and then what
i want to do is i want to make sure that
the edges
are totally smooth
a lot of dust is coming out
just making sure every edge is
nice and smooth
underneath
okay and so i've refiled that nut slot a
little bit
and actually it looks pretty good i
think there was definitely a bit of a
snag
going on so now i'm going to put on
a new gut string and i'm going to see if
it makes any wear and if it does i think
i'm just going to take it out and i'll
file more
and then i'll put it back in until it
goes smoothly like these
like these other ones are are working so
that's a quick solution now the same
thing could happen by the way in the
bridge side if you're breaking strings
on the bridge side
the saddle this white piece here might
have
a sharp edge same thing take the
sandpaper and file just
the slot there um that could be a really
easy temporary
solution to breaking strings especially
if you're using gut
and they're very expensive you don't
want to break so
uh i think i'll now time another string
and then hopefully
i'll be good to go okay i hope that
helped
[Music]
cheers
you